because some stereo executive is
watching this right now saying we need
to remake momento someone is doing right
now there's a studio executive i see you
i see you studio executive whoever you
are
we had this question come in on our
youtube channel from kp
is the name what can creatives do to
help make the film industry better and
more free for artistic creation how can
we get back to making great movies again
kp first of all that is a great question
how can we get back
to making movies that are great and by
great you i'm going to guess that you
mean just a broad appeal and a
satisfying experience an experience
where you walk out of the theater and
you know wow not only did you enjoy that
experience you wanna you wanna go back
and see the movie several times
i have not had that feeling
very often
want to go back and see a movie again
because i want to
you know
just ride that ride it feels it's almost
like a ride an exhilaration
you know
so
how do we get back to that i think that
we have to do is
really foster and mentor talent young
talent
not simply
fill a writer's room and there's seven
different writers for a project and
really really mentor
new and up-and-coming talent
and foster that
one
number two and i know that hollywood is
is averse to this but almost everything
you see that's on a large scale in terms
of a big budget
is based on pre-existing material
a comic book that's been around a comic
book property that's been around for 80
years
you know
a stage play
that is
you know been on broadway for decades
or a remake
of a cartoon and now this is the
live-action version and whatnot so
seeking out something original
something original that that it may have
some source material but hasn't been
made five six seven eight times i know
that's a risk
i know that's a risk
but i think it's important to seek it
out you know san diego comic-con
used to be which is something it's an
event that i've attended
for
longer than i care to remember but
that used to be a place
that development executives from
hollywood would go down
to san diego from los angeles and they
would seek out like
a small
comic book that no one's ever heard of
that has
a an amazing hook an amazing story it
was a place to look for new material i
feel like that has to come back and in
addition i think it's a more informed
development community so that would be
my my third thing is a development
community that really reads
that isn't just aware of
you know like oh yeah yeah i know star
trek
you know
but you know has seen all the episodes
of
every star trek series ever made
right
in including the you know
unaired pilot
right like just has has seen it all so i
think a just more informed
base of people working in hollywood that
that while they're burdened with the
concerns of like well how is this going
to fit marketing
stockholders this
just be aware
of the
you know other creative possibilities
that are out there including original
intellectual property i even hate using
that word ip on intellectual property
but you know there are very few
creatives in hollywood now that are even
given the power to be able to exercise
that christopher nolan is is one of the
people that's that's been able to do
that but there are far few
so and then i think part of it is also
developing talent so
attending your major film festivals and
looking for movies made by
small up-and-coming filmmakers i mean
i've seen it i've seen it in the room
where i've seen like you know a movie
made for ten thousand dollars
shot with just like
you know almost not you know just like
these are the resources we had but you
see the creativity through the adversity
you know there's
not a lot of money there's not but you
see like oh there's a vision there
there's a vision there's a visionary
that's behind that so i think it's
really seeking that out you know it's
it's not much different than
you know
someone going out and
seeking talent for a football team you
know or professional you know a
professional sports team right you got
to seek out talent and that means you've
got to look at people as they're coming
up through the ranks which is going to
be your film festivals and everyone
who's been in a position
that is now successful whether it's a
james gunn or whether it's a christopher
nolan whether it's a taika watiti
all of them started in indie film they
all started with small movies taikawa td
had a movie that was at sundance
christopher nolan had a movie at both
slam dance and then the following year
sundance with momento his first movie
following was at slam dance
james gunn started with
exploitation movies he worked for lloyd
kaufman at troma pictures
so
these creatives
you know really were able to cut their
teeth
when kind of it didn't matter you know
the stakes were low
you know the budgets were low the stakes
were low they could make mistakes it's
fine it's okay
and
then we're able to kind of like okay get
bigger and big bigger budgets and prove
themselves certainly you know all of
those filmmakers taika with td james
gunn christopher nolan all of them
you know started with smaller projects
and built along the way
and were able to make mistakes at a time
when it necessarily
didn't matter but also they had that
they were able to develop that creative
vision
you know especially in particular if you
look at the movie that james gunn made
before he was hired by marvel to do
guardians of the galaxy
he did a movie called super starring
rayne wilson
and it's a superhero movie
about a guy who's kind of fed up with
the world and just decides he's going to
be a
you know superhero and he's gonna fight
crime
it's also a comedy i mean it's very much
it's no different tone wise with a lot
of james gunn's later work but you see
it the seeds of it in super really
whereas kind of all came together
and and from that he was able to then do
a big budget marvel superhero movie
where he was given pretty much creative
rain
he put together and james has talked
about this in other interviews you can
look it up he put together like what
they call uh a presentation some would
call it a look book it's this is what he
wanted the world to be so he he really
laid out like this is the tone of
guardians the galaxy this is the
universe it's the cosmic marvel universe
which is different than other types of
marvel movies it was you know
the first to kind of delve in that arena
and
you know
when you track the careers of those
creatives who did much smaller work and
move up the scale i think that needs to
be developed more even if it's a matter
of you find a filmmaker at a
you know from a film festival or a
filmmaker that put out a movie on a
small label like a gravitas ventures or
wild eye releasing or october coast
these are the small indie
you know
indie film distributors
that or there's a company called indie
rights these small look at these movies
and you can see
you know there are filmmakers there are
gems
there are diamonds in the rough that
have put out films at all of those
companies that are ready to maybe go to
maybe not necessarily a hundred million
dollars but the next level up and then
see what's possible
and i feel like that type of talent
needs to be
needs
needs to be fostered mentored grown you
know
would memento be successful if it came
out today if we'd never heard of
christopher nolan
i actually think i actually think if
memento came out today it would be
successful it's such an original story
it's so
it's it's
you know one of those things where it
work it's a movie memento is on a short
list of movies that i see require a
second viewing to completely
grasp all of it then you notice that
it's like oh it's story's converging
right like it's
it's it's such a fascinating
you know
you know twist on a traditional
narrative
right with familiar aspects
things we you know we've seen before
it's like okay it's kind of a noir a
mystery right but there's more to it so
yeah i actually think that that would be
successful but i don't want to talk
about this too much because some stereo
executive is watching this right now
saying we need to remake momento
someone is doing right now there's a
studio executive i see you
i see you studio executive whoever you
are
remake memento yeah sure why not all
right fine
go ahead
but give the opportunity to a young
up-and-coming filmmaker if you're gonna
do that
instead of post-its he'll use notes
who knows yeah so notes on the phone
right you could you could update it but
in a way that's
a way that's clever and interesting not
that compromises the story i re yeah
yeah yeah that's a whole other thing